what's going on there reject nation we
are here today to watch the fourth
episode
of peacemaker loving the freak out of
this series so much guys if you could do
an active piece by hitting that like
button that would be amazeballs also if
you could subscribe and click the
notification while you get notified when
our next reaction for peacemaker is up
that would be very much appreciated big
thank you to the boys over at prepper
for helping us edit down these
highlights
lastly full length watchalongs or at our
patreon page special thank you to all
who have joined our patreon page and
become superior jax your support has
been overwhelming in every way possible
so thank you for doing that to our
emotions let's get into it thank the
lord for james gunn
you'll fall over all the time look
stupid everyone will laugh at you who's
gonna laugh at you for falling over
because you don't have a toe
you can't walk if you lose your
metatarsal that's like the knuckle of
the pinky toe but if you just lose your
pinky it's fine
[Laughter]
that's the response
because right now the world needs a son
of a [ __ ] and you're the only one i got
well i guess him now too
i once saw made an entire wendy's
restaurant vigilante ate a restaurant no
matter eater lad that's his power you
need anything
hey these butterflies
are like alien bugs that crawl up into
human brains and control people
get some rest come back tonight we'll
explain the whole thing finally yeah
it's about time
i swing by my dad's on the way home he's
got a helmet i think i can use in all
this
oh no
listen i've been meaning to thank you
for allowing me to be tortured last
night
you were just supporting me and helping
me to become the best me that i could be
someone who doesn't spill the beans
while being electrocuted and having half
his toe cut off you seem to be walking
okay well i'll probably never walk as
good again
thank you
i've never had a friend quite like you
his greatest weapon is passive
aggression
you wear too much of a candy ass to take
a little torture oh yeah i would have
been real guilty you see that that right
there was angry no it wasn't it was
normal i was i was agreeing with you
i love this guy facility has been closed
and forensics teams have been sweeping
the area zoo officials say they have no
idea how the gorilla was stolen i don't
see that gorilla gorilla grodd
oh
you said you were a superhero like
batman
do you have a cover of super villains no
he doesn't
so maybe you're not a superhero after
all
oh
old man my coteries super villains is
six feet [ __ ] under there you see
batman doesn't kill people
he's a jackass who wrestles with
murderers dressed like clowns and throws
them in prison so they can break out of
prison and then murder more people
riddle me this how many people you think
batman's indirectly murdered by being
too much of a candy ass
you're definitely a supervillain you're
gonna end up in jail with your father
soon enough oop he revealed it
yeah
if you want to come back we can talk
about this like adults no no my dad's in
jail i'm going to see him smith i don't
think that's wise oh yeah well [ __ ] you
man you people only [ __ ] care about
yourselves anyway
oh
me
that's probably because you're the one
who framed facemaker's father
[Laughter]
hey it's like rick flag's shirt good
catch you want me to take the jail see
your dad
yeah
even though i know he's a racist
shouldn't he kill him then no i'm not
gonna kill my dad why not
because i love him whoa
your dad is not a good man not to the
world and especially not to you
he's still family
well he has to do what he has to do i
guess
i took you vigilante
[Laughter]
do the face thing again
why are you limping snowboarding
accident totally unrelated in any way to
vigilante i don't even know who
vigilante is
who is he
the people i'm working with they did
their own thing switch your fingerprints
for mine they did what i know it's
[ __ ] up but i had nothing to do with
it i saw you come out of your mother's
cooch i should have slit your throat in
there after my wow god
you're a rube like you've always been
i'm not letting my own damn son work for
them i'm no rat but the first chance i
get i'm spilling everything technically
that yeah
exactly makes you a rat
technically just factually get the [ __ ]
out of my sight
i don't think chris is ever gonna be
happy as long as his father's around
uh-oh i just wish there was some way he
would just
oh i look on his face
go away she's doing it yeah
oh you are wallering you gotta go do
something
assassinate someone really quick
[ __ ] oh maybe she wasn't intending to i
can't tell anymore
[Music]
i'm just watching him do this
yeah i guess
is he trying to get arrested i don't
care i'll get on the ground all day long
oh crap i checked the restraints they
were tight i don't know how the [ __ ] he
got loose
oh
who the [ __ ] do you think judo makes
sense
i think cobra kai just got out our
reaction to cobra kai finale is going up
this week
a hallway window
[Music]
[Laughter]
classic
you have a weird polishy body personal
insults
real mature shrimp huh you have no
idea
butterflies they're not what you think
they are
oh
who did that
is it
oh
i wasn't expecting that
i was gonna win that fight
[ __ ]
i never killed a man before
oh you still haven't their heart stops
beating they just concentrate and move a
kidney up into its place
circulates the blood through the system
no this is not something that happens
just a few times
no one has ever replaced their own heart
with a kidney
hey what do you think he's about to say
the butterflies i know what you think
they're
ask him while he's still breathing
love that smug confidence
who is this actor he's awesome yeah
every time i turn around one of you is
doing something [ __ ] up
i thought walla gave me soldiers instead
it's a [ __ ] apple dumpling gang
classic pool worthy apple dumpling
incompetent dinguses but they always
triumph in the end
he could kill vigilante and without
vigilante we're taking on the
butterflies one man down
half a man down the guy's a psychopath
this is the four of us against the damn
alien invasion we need a psychopath
healing invasion keep your eye on your
goddamn opponent
oh here we go let's each say something
that we're grateful for that black
people have contributed to american
culture
but i'm grateful the black people gave
us rock and roll music
z
38 special all those guys owe everything
to black america
and then white redneck music would just
sound like well what it sounded like
before black people which was the wet
sloppy sounds of [ __ ] your sister
which one of you dumb sister [ __ ]
tiki torch carrying sloth from the
goonies looking pieces of [ __ ] wants to
go next oh i love you your favorite
contribution to black american culture
was all the black guys who [ __ ] your
mom in the ass while you watched from
the closet wow
this dude did nothing
you're bad dad i need to talk to
detective song now
i need your crap to detect this song i
got information to work on this case my
son's trying to kill me get me detective
song
oh you oh no it's just getting worse
what's it say in my file about what my
dad did when i was a kid it says that he
trained you to kill from when you were
very young and it says that your brother
died under mysterious circumstances
and that you were involved in that so
his dad is playing himself from walk the
line again
[Laughter]
huh
they can't take his mask off i was
wondering about that
i feel like you would want to know his
identity
oh
mm-hmm
peacemaker
what a joke
hahaha
oh
he's trying to always have such
emotional death
that's crazy yeah he's definitely
perfect in this straw
leota i think i found something great
i'll be right over
he's a butterfly
oh jesus
yeah
good call i know i thought it last
episode i don't know if i said it i
don't remember he was talking about not
having emotion yeah or was it not part
of the reaction right
true a good call either way
yeah talking about his feelings he might
be like a rogue butterfly like some of
the conflict stuff i'm learning to feel
and everything and maybe he's i think
clues that he's like doesn't believe in
the cause learning humanity feelings
yeah or maybe all the other butterflies
are victims of a potential genocide on
his part oh yeah
i don't know it could be either still
like hunting butterflies like kill them
kill you know
so it might be the first one that sides
with humanity vigilante you've had a lot
of [ __ ] stupid ideas put a duck in a
human costume
that's the stupidest idea you've ever
[ __ ] had and it's offensive to me
cause i have a soul
not a duck
he's deleted him proptics
best post credit scenes in the bids
good
all right guys wow that was that was
something
well that was a very different episode
it was very different
um really reflective
real melancholy vibes uh throughout from
beginning to end and i really appreciate
that you know as
one of the unique things about this show
is i think the
the way they've been transitioning
within their tones where it starts off
very funny
and then eventually
like funny and heightened
and then it was really around
somewhere in episode three where it
started to feel like okay we're getting
a little bit more of that darker quality
to it a little bit more of that
pathos quality well actually i think it
was actually an episode two well it was
it's always been there actually i think
about it it's always sort of been there
it's just been i think what it has been
has been mainly the other qualities have
been more of the accentuated stuff where
the
the fun and the excitement the high
energy
um you know the irreverent humor and all
that
has been a little bit more at the
forefront whereas that
was
supporting and secondary
to
the characters
uh internal
you know reflections that they were
going through in this particular episode
it was uh more on the the deeper end and
i thought it was cool to have
you know this more realistic approach
where
they've been going on missions they have
judo master but there's a down period
time there's it's a movie it's always
go go go and then like the settling down
calming moments or usually
you know like 10 to 20 minutes and
they're not something that you could
take 45 minutes for an episode to do
like while there's some funny moments in
here and while there's definitely some
uh like cool action
it's not the main takeaway whatsoever
the main like john cena's performance
here and and getting the backstory like
this through because i think one thing
that james gunn's style
whether that be translating it with
through his writing communication with
directors editors he's producer he's
still the helm
still the one who helmed this show
you know like we i think sometimes we
think about his music associated with
more of a
romanticizing type of scene whether
that's something as direct as love or
attraction
and yet here hear
like those flashbacks of him as a child
you know like
the peacemaker being a joke
quality and then you're really
humanizing him and showing that
he's really just a tortured soul here
who's
just so
lost and yearns for a connection
much like john that's right he's it's
right away yeah yeah and that's and
we're both you know impeccably buffed
too it's true definitely yeah
but
at the same time
vigilante is the [ __ ]
he is such a good character
i even like that really human moment
where um
uh what's her name the blonde girl
parkour harcourt okay where um james
gunn's girlfriend yes
girlfriend gun
where harcourt and and adrian chase when
they meet each other at the end and
heather's kind of how she has an
understanding
towards him you know she can be kind of
cold closed off usually
but when
you know she sees him walking and she
picks him up
it's not the way she
behaves where it's this
very reserved approach towards
chris
he uh you know it's like she sees him in
in this light of he was just trying to
help out his friend
you know yeah
um and you get a lot of those uh
everyone's just so human in this in this
show you see the struggle of
these people who don't remind a lot of
them i mean like you you have
economos who's not used to being out in
the field
and
uh at a bio who's definitely not used to
being out in the field and you're seeing
the toll that this is taking on them and
you're seeing the weight
of everything peacemaker has always
strived for but he's just kind of
suffering on the inside oh yeah
he yearns for for love and it's it's
such a great
breakdown and you're seeing how every
his belief system that he's built this
whole identity off of
has left let him down a road of being
disillusioned
[Music]
with that and i i think uh
yeah i'm looking for one sentence here
to sound smart and i think i finally got
there
took me a while it was beautiful though
it's a meanwhile it's 155 very long
terrified or something i think i got it
yeah
and uh yeah that was uh it was
there's something that's so enveloping
about this show and i it's it's this is
a what's that weird that an unusual
voice you can't and might you can't
quite put your finger on sometimes
and that there's something so unique
about it
because it it
what i love is that it just sticks to a
tone you know what i mean yeah it sticks
to uh
some shows try to do like all the tones
in one like what's this what's the kind
of tones we're trying to cover and we
try to keep it all present in one and
while they do that here it's like no
this one's more this kind of episode
let's not worry so much about trying to
be funny yeah
well there's like some funny scenes that
it's not it doesn't seem like concern
with that in a lot of moments yeah
because i mean there's so much inherent
humor just to how clearly the characters
are drawn and how clear their world
views are
and this one yeah i i
it felt like a recuperating and and
re-organizing kind of episode just for
the position that they're in but you're
also yeah getting a glimpse into how
isolating this is and how kind of sad
and alone
it leaves most everybody feeling for one
reason or another and it reminded me of
that thing he said to economists in this
first or second episode that whole joke
bit about like you know we could
probably be really good friends but i'm
pushing you away because i don't want to
open up to that you know and i felt that
again here with adrian chase in the car
where they're having that really passive
aggressive back and forth where he's
trying to pretend like he's not upset
about peacemaker not really caring about
him getting tortured or whatever like
there are all these
feelings that people because of the need
to be tough and because they need to you
know make the hard decisions you know
people are holding up and bottling up
and it makes for a nice i think
character-oriented tension because aside
from the reveal at the end with mern
it's more like now these people have
more and more reasons not to trust each
other and the fragility of their you
know uh
working bond as a unit is really kind of
at the center in an episode like this
because half the action is like we can't
have peacemaker finding out about what
we did to his oh craig crap he found out
what he did with what we did to his
dad's and how he's going to go there and
i love that
you know i think james gunn is also
especially good at
making it not feel like there are plot
mechanics happening it's like he just
goes in and does talk to him and he
gives them some information it's
probably bad for
uh for auggie to have
and
yeah like the way that he's able to
orchestrate a believable mess based on
these character motivations of again
yeah like people also looking for this
approval
to some extent everybody has some kind
of approval that they are sort of
desperate to earn at least as far as the
team is concerned and so everyone at
some point has an opportunity to act
sort of in whatever they think suits
that best interest of the overall
mission and like
he's good at drawing these believably
wacky but also kind of
touchingly dysfunctional groups and uh
yeah like you feel
i'm curious to see what kind of you know
team formation comes by the end of it if
there is a sort of triumphant like no no
we finally all figured out how we work
best together or not because it seems
like this team is hanging on by a thread
and i like that
tension
and and yeah like the the silent way in
which he brings in some of that
backstory it's like you know there's a
lot you can surmise about chris in
august's relationship but seeing even
those flashes of like we don't know
exactly verbatim what happened to his
brother for instance but we have a
pretty solid idea from those flashes and
i feel like to play it that way is
that much more impactful because it's in
the emotion it's deep within the emotion
of the character in that scene whether
or not chris's emotion plays a little
bit goofy just because of who the
character is it's still palpable and
it's so tangible and even the use of his
name like i figured like they've used
that breaking between peacemaker versus
chris in a you know in a subtle but also
i think very kind of striking way
and i appreciated the way that that you
know continued through here
and uh
i think probably just the most badass
moment of this episode it's like it's
there were some good fights and there
were some like you know moments that
made you go
but the one like truly badass sequence
here for me was yeah when when chase
sits down with them at the you know in
the jail with the poker game and starts
grilling them on their favorite
contributions from black americans to
society
like that was the one where it's like
all right we're stepping up and doing
something you know kind of bad ass but
the rest of the time yeah like it
maintained all of those
you know really enjoyable like you said
that enjoyable array of tones but in a
package that felt appropriately sort of
baleful for all the things that have
happened and it is i mean you know
ostensibly we're sort of through act one
into act two now of the overall story
and i think that first three makes for a
nice place setting and now it makes
sense to kind of go into a valley after
that for a little bit
uh yeah we're at the midpoint i mean he
touched on something that i think is
what the show is ultimately doing is the
the way how
i often see it brought up with batman is
you know like this this story you know
it's not really about batman it's about
bruce wayne
and and i think what this show does is
it
suicide squad introduced us to
peacemaker and this is showing us chris
yeah and that's like the personality the
human behind it
and they still maintain humanizing even
when you don't i think i think what the
show does so well is they humanize them
when you least expect it in the most
and the most uh
sometimes it could feel like a peculiar
moment where they're
like like when um
adebayo is visiting
it stops chris when he's on his way to
to see his dad at the at the police
station at jail
and there's this one shot where you know
like
he's being confronted with the fact that
his dad is a horrible person as a racist
and they're having that whole parental
discussion
about the how we how we view our parents
and that we want to believe like yeah
they're flawed but on the inside they're
good but sometimes we have to accept the
fact that they really just aren't good
people
and which is a hard thing to accept and
um which i think in in a lot of way it's
very i think it's a very relatable uh
quality to imprint
onto the character for for the audience
uh because i i think
there's a lot of people out there who
come from abusive families where you
know and his dad is is the i'm surprised
chris didn't end up that way you know
where he doesn't
they don't portray him to be racist at
all not a hateful guy yeah yeah no
he he's always been uh very everything
about him is very childlike and just
wants to
he just wants to be loved that's that's
everything about his characters he just
he just wan no matter what it is he
wants to be loved it makes sense where
you know in suicide squad you see him on
a military you know covert mission
whereas here he's in his hometown
where
you know like you would you would expect
that it wouldn't be the same type of
vibe whereas the military you have
peacemakers that would do a job to serve
his country
and they at least flesh out for him what
it is he has to do and why
and
he's not even really understanding why
he's doing what he's doing but back to
that moment i was talking about we're
outside of the jail
when
adebayo's confronting him
there's this like one shot
where it cuts to
adrian just watching him
because there's a lot you have the scene
in the car where he's like your dad's
racist and they make they make
humor out of it
they bring the funny in that scene
but you see in that look where adrian
when he's just watching him of
oh
everything he was saying he was saying
from a sympathetic way of a caring place
you know like he questions he's like why
don't you just kill him you might have
never killed your dad well adrian's a
little bit more psychotic um
do you know what look i'm talking about
when uh
adebayo's confronting him and then chris
looks at john cena looks at adrian for
just like a brief moment it's like this
one second shot and chris is just adrian
just standing there just looking at him
watching
and he's realized like i think in that
moment he's that's right before he says
but he's still my father
of
he's real like that's the truth and i
think i'm like for for james
for some credit has to go to the
director of this episode oh yeah but
for the for the type of
visual language that james gunn strikes
which is so often associated with his
dialogue i think what he can do really
well is also bring out powerful moments
in in certain quiet sections
and i think that's the most when i feel
like i'm really learning about who these
characters are a lot of it is
things that
um like you said you can surmise just
because of
watching how these characters are some
things they say in their humor but their
most authentic
traits seem to shine through most and
just
in their expressive
times when they're not even
talking
so yeah oh yeah yeah it's really it's
really strong in that arena and it's uh
yeah this is a good one and i think what
they're doing with robert patrick is
very fascinating because
while it doesn't seem like they're
trying to get you to
it seems like they're doing exactly what
adebayo said about him
that
he he's a
awful human being and they're just
letting him be an awful human being
and they're not trying to get you to
see the maybe the show
yeah maybe and maybe they will
but at this point i don't feel like the
show's interested or
it has a motivation to do such a thing
it seems like what they want they're
letting him be that but
they're still making him
feel
very human in that approach like i made
i made the joke about like he's playing
the johnny cash dad again
uh you know i had go ahead and use it
like the wrong kid died and i'm saying
it could be that yeah it could be yeah
it could just be like the most generic i
was just grieving over your brother so
much that i lost sight of you yeah but
but he's not he's not that he still
feels like
i think that's what makes robert
patrick's performance so strong is
because the writing of him is feels like
a real guy yeah
it's not a caricature of a racist guy it
feels much meaner and more uncomfortable
than that
yeah because he's someone who you could
walk who could walk amongst us who you
would only suspect but wouldn't know
unless you got to know him yeah
you know absolutely so i i think this is
a really really cool show
in every regard this is the kind of
episode that i think on
i'm hoping that this is not the kind of
episode that would make audiences like
be like boring oh it slowed down after
episode three yeah i mean if this was
one of the
disney plus marvel shows this is odds
are people would say that right the
episode that's only devoted to character
development and slowing down bring back
to action which is usually the third or
fourth episode in those shows to be fair
and uh and we tend to love those
episodes uh a lot
uh but this commits to it because of the
fact that it's hbo max it's r-rated
um
[Music]
that it it can be
[Music]
just more
adult
in every regard yeah more mature so it
could
be
super adults with its violence and its
humor
and then it could be super adult with
its character exploration and themes
and like those flashbacks are disturbing
they're very just they're they're
disturbing and [ __ ] john cena man
like i i just
i don't know what it is i'm like this
guy can
it's weird i can act like he's a really
great actor he's he's great
like how many roles can you think of
like this where you could
i cause because i i remember you know
walking out of suicide squad and saying
and i remember when i called you and i
was like dude like john cena in this is
the first role i've ever seen of him
where i i just
only saw the character he was playing
and i wasn't seeing john cena like he
was very believable
and but it still leaned into the john
cena strength that you would
be presumptuous about of why you would
cast john cena in that role yeah you
know
and then here i'm like oh he can carry a
show because he's also got the depth
and i think that's what's so surprising
about his performance is there's so much
depth
because he can do the comedy of like the
freaking judo master like the martial
arts bit of like all it takes is
concentration
move your kidney up into your heart but
this is blood flow it was so funny and
it's like that's why you cast john cena
for the [ __ ] like that usually like yeah
like the comedy and whatever
um or to be a tough guy or something
but man when he is
those scenes of robert patrick or
the scenes by himself
oh yeah yeah he's had a bunch of those
uh so far and he's yeah he's still good
you still just see the character and
yeah i think you're absolutely right
it's like john cena up until this point
has yeah like has a lot of goodwill i've
enjoyed him in a ton of things and i
think we've we've kind of been at that
precipice of like okay yeah he's got a
lot charm got a lot of comedic ability
but you know that last little layer is
you know the the believable emotional
depth and i feel like this show could
have gone really wrong or it could have
been
not quite
as like it could have been just shy of
how great it's been if he didn't have
that extra ounce and i think yeah
whatever
whatever he has done up until this point
to get that little bit of extra you know
emotional nuance visible in his
performances i think is is
fantastic because it really ties all of
this together he brings a level of
sincere sensitivity i think is what it
is you know
and uh i really
i really appreciate this like he
he
is
i'm trying to think is it you know they
make the jokes about him being racist
but i can't
recall anything where i'm like he's
portrayed as a racist not really i mean
there have been a couple of moments
where it seems like he's saying like
they're they're funny but i feel like in
the first or second episode there was
something about him being
very uh embracing of various cultures or
something like that so i feel like he
may be you know like racist in the way
that like ignorantly racist where like
i'm sure he's got some problematic
things to say he's got some like yeah
he's got some learning but he's not
not racist and not that this is a
justification
totally racist yeah not like he's going
to hurt someone because of the color of
the race yeah like at least this show
hasn't
had a scene that displays that i can't
think of anything in the suicide squad
that showed that so yeah it's apparently
it's something in the character's
history and or maybe it's just by nature
of association with your dad being white
dragon um he strikes me as a character
who's not racist but who might still
reveal themselves to be ignorant in that
area even when trying to be helpful i
feel like he would stereotype people
yeah yeah you know
um
yeah i think just because that's what he
knows yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
black people love that right yeah yeah
kind of thing yeah yeah or asian people
don't like this you know
something like that
um not because you're black but you know
you happen to be black
i can see him getting into a very
understandable uh uh you know ignorance
based misunderstanding or something like
that yeah yeah
but he doesn't seem morally defending
him because he's a white man a white man
can get away with it yeah it's not that
let's say we're providing no nuance in
this discussion whatsoever
i think that is also a good thing
because it's clear yeah you look at
their history and i'm like i'm sure this
guy has some problematic things to say
because i mean when it comes to like
sexual things he does across the show
yeah
so you know it's like i'm sure it's
there but yeah it it seems to draw that
marked difference of like this this
doesn't seem like somebody who wants to
be racist who wants to do that kind of
damage and probably just has some nasty
kinks to work out because of that very
relevant i mean conundrum of
i love my dad except my dad's terrible
what do i do and in trying to gain that
approval i'm sure that there's some
stuff that yeah is problematic coming
from chris
in that pursuit
but yeah it's interesting to see a
character who
can exist problematically because of
course they would be a problematic
person and maybe they'll be a little
less problematic by the time this is
done
well i like the hell out of it i think i
i think it's uh i think it's an amazing
show yeah
um and it's it's really easy to get lost
in it and i i likes
i guess my last thing i'll say is why i
like saying that about it is because
it's not when i say usually when you say
like you get lost in it
it's usually associated with something
that is a little bit more fantastical or
supernatural or
sci-fi
and
this is not that this is not that you
know while it has those qualities
obviously
um like especially sci-fi and and
superhero
you know it it it's
it's just like
hanging out with with the characters
it's like the excitement's not from the
mission
yeah you know and uh the mission's just
a cherry on top to give us some like
cool violent [ __ ]
although i do think the fight with judo
master and john if i had a criticism i
don't think the fight would you know i
thought the fight with judo master in
the last episode was really good didn't
really care for the fight here someone
kind of off about it there were moments
but it could have been just captured i
think more sumptuously like i think they
did some nice things in terms of having
like little
tiny locked
yeah a little tiny like crash zooms or
things like that to like accentuate
certain impact moments but uh yeah as
far as fight scenes go it was not the
most like graceful or not the most like
gracefully captured i would say
especially a one-on-one with judo master
and peacemaker and the light it seems
like you'd want to make that like a
full-on set piece
yeah but something about it felt like i
was still watching
choreographed actors
you know
yeah it's like i liked how much of a of
an unflashy sort of brawl it was but
there is yeah it didn't quite feel like
it was full full-on fight speed or
something yeah yeah yeah
but still um that's
so minor because the takeaway is not
usually
that
the one i mean the takeaway of that
scene is it just becomes the
the butterflies you don't understand you
know what is it that we don't understand
you know
all right guys well
thanks for being here
so sorry
for johnny excuse me
uh thanks for being here and um
we'll catch you guys soon